see Sonic the heart of your system
[Music]
alright guys dominating here for kick gu
and after a three-week wait since the
initial launch of the r-tx 2060 super
and the RT x 2070 super today we can
present our review of invidious RT x
2080 super and not only do we have a
founders edition here but we also have
Emma size RTX 2080 super gaming extra as
well so if you quickly go over some of
the course specs what's new of the 2080
super it is still using the tu-104 GPU
which is actually the basis for the
original r-tx 2080 unlike that original
card though the 2080 super is a full
implementation of the t1 and for GPU so
instead of having 46 SMS actually has
two more up to 48 and that means it also
has 128 extra CUDA cores giving it a
total of 3072
versus 2944 on the original 2080
that may not sound like a very big spec
Bunton that's not really an extra
hundred 28 CUDA cores but NVIDIA is also
supplying the 20 80 super with new
memory so we're so far we've seen all of
the other r-tx cards running its GDD are
6 memory at 14 gigabits per second now
of the 20 80 super they are running new
chips clocked at fifteen point five
gigabits per second as for boost quacks
as well so the founders Edition 2080
super is clocked at 18 15 megahertz
boost
whereas this Emma site is actually
factory overclocked by 30 megahertz
giving it an eighteen forty five
megahertz boost in terms of pricing as
well the RT X 20 a few super has a MSRP
of 669 pounds here in the UK and the
founders Edition does come in at that
MSRP we are still waiting for confirmed
pricing at the time of filming for this
msi card but based on our past
experiences particularly given that we
looked at this same model for the 2070
super and that was significantly more
expensive so I think it's safe to say we
can expect something similar for this
2080 super as well that's really it for
our just quick spec introduction for
this new card however we're gonna dive
straight into the performance now and
it's worth saying in this video we're
going to be looking at our 1440p
benchmarks although we do of course have
1080p and 4k results over on keep guru
dotnet it
you want to check those out so if we get
the charts up for you now I think it's
probably not too much of a surprise that
given 2080 super does have 128 more CUDA
cores than the original 2080 and it's
memory is also caught faster it's no
surprise to see 2080 super outperforming
the original 2080 in every single one of
our benchmarks that being said the gap
isn't actually that big I thought maybe
it would be slightly bigger especially
with the high cop memory in actual fact
in some of our 1080p charts we saw the
difference being as little as two
percent although often at 1080p we are
introducing a little bit more of a CPU
bottleneck whereas the biggest
difference we actually saw came at 4k
where the 20/80 super proved seven
percent faster than the 20 80 across all
of our benchmarks however 20/80 super is
on average four percent faster than the
original 2080 on top of that the MSI
gaming Xtreme does outperform the twenty
eighty super frown position by two
percent so not very much of a lead bear
but is definitely something to factor in
if we compare the twenty eighty super to
the twenty seventy super here we can see
an 11 percent performance increase for
the twenty eighty super which is on
average and then again looking at
something like the AMD rx 5700 XT here
we can see a sixteen percent performance
increase support in videos new card
bearing in mind that the twenty eighty
super is actually almost two hundred
pounds more expensive than the twenty
seventy super and almost double the
price of the 5700 XT it really doesn't
paint it in a very good light in terms
of overall value but will save most of
that for our conclusion that is pretty
much it for our overall look at
performance however like we said it's
not really a big leap forward from the
original twenty eighty at all and we
also said you only gain an extra two
percent when going with an factory
overclocked card like this MSI gaming
Xtreme
[Music]
that being said we did actually see some
pretty decent games when manly
overclocking so starting with our fans
edition here we were able to add at 110
megahertz to the GPU core but 1215
megahertz to their memory so at 2.5
gigabits per second we're world increase
as for our MSI gaming Xtreme we could
only add an extra 70 megahertz to the
GPU core but then we actually
overclocked even further with an extra
14 hundred megahertz or 2.8 gigabits per
second in the real world so definitely
two pretty good overclocks
especially on the memory side of things
where we significantly increased the
overall bandwidth and accordingly we saw
a very healthy increase to our average
frame rates going back through our 1440p
benchmarks we actually saw frame rate
increases typically between 8 to 10 FPS
depending on the game so overall very
healthy and for the found Edition that
makes it an average performance increase
of 9% it wasn't quite as big for the MSI
card with an average performance
increase of 7% that was mainly because
we weren't able to overhaul the core as
much it was already slightly factory
overclocked but even so still an extra
70 megahertz definitely improve things
in terms of overall clock speed these
over clocks weren't actually enough to
fully close the gap on the 28 ETI but we
definitely saw that there is a lot of
potential a lot of untapped Headroom for
these cards particularly when it comes
to that g6 memory like we already said
like 18 gigabits per second over 15.5
stop I think is a very decent increase
and an overall increase of 9% for our
fans addition is definitely not
something to be sniffed at we're gonna
move on now to look at the cards
themselves although spoiler alert we've
actually seen both of these designs
before the 2080 Super is actually
reusing the same card design as both the
2070 Super as well as the original 2080
whereas this gaming exterior from MSI is
actually the same design as the 2070
super gaming exterior we looked at only
a couple weeks ago starting with the
founders know like we said it is the
same as the 2070 Super but that is
definitely not
thing not only is the card incredibly
well-built with its aluminium shroud but
the dual axial fan design is much better
than the previous blower style cards we
saw from Nvidia and we'll look at things
like our temperatures and acoustics very
shortly being one of the new super cards
as well we can also see that new mirror
finish section in between the two fans
while NVIDIA has also printed the Super
logo here in green so it's functionally
it is the same as the original 2080
although that mirror finish section and
the green logo does just help kind of
spruce things up a little bit in terms
of the aesthetic turning the card over
now we also have this same silver
backplate which is full length and kind
of wraps around at the end to give it an
almost unibody design while we can also
see it again the 2080 Super logo here
printed in the middle of the back page
as for our power requirements again same
as 2070 Super with one six pin and one
eight pin while we can also see the same
video outputs with three display ports
one HDMI and then one USB see that does
pretty much wrap it up like we said it
is the same as the 2070 Super so if you
have seen that card if you've seen the
original 2080 flat matter they are
functionally exactly the same the msi on
the other hand is quite a lot bigger
that's probably the first thing I
noticed it actually measured in at 328
millimeters by one hundred and forty by
fifty six point five millimeters and you
can also see that has got a triple fan
cooler and these are using MSI's new tox
3.0 fan design interestingly two of the
fans actually measure 100 millimeters
but both that are kind of further on the
right while the fan which is nearest the
i/o bracket actually measures ninety
millimeters so it's just slightly
smaller elsewhere the card is still
using that same gunmetal gray and
plastic shroud we saw on the 2070 super
gaming Xtreme and I definitely think it
is a good looking card although it
doesn't feel quite as premium as the all
aluminium found Edition I do really like
that backplate on this card however it
is made of brushed metal but you can
actually see it's kind of brushed in two
different directions so depending on how
the light hits it that gives it a really
nice two-tone look I've said in previous
videos I do really like this design it
also covers the full length of the PCB
and is mostly plane apart from the MSI
dragon logo positioned on the right hand
side of the backplate
now we did also take this car apart to
get a look at the PCB and yet you
guessed it is the same design as the
2070 super gaming X tree although MSI
has actually beefed up their power
delivery it's got a ten plus two phase
configuration on this twenty eighty
super whereas the twenty seventy super
was an eight plus two power phase
configuration we also get a look at
those new fifteen point five gigabits
per second memory chips and on this
particular model they are actually from
Samsung not micron although we did speak
to Nvidia and they confirmed that you
could get chips from either micron or
Samsung just like the rest of the RT X
series so nothing new there although it
was interesting that actually both of
our day one cards had Samsung memory so
just something to point out the last
thing to look at is that cool and again
it hasn't changed from a 2070 super
model it's got seven nickel plated heat
pipes six of those actually measure six
millimeters in diameter while the last
one is slightly thicker at eight
millimeters and we can also see that the
GPU itself contacts with a smaller coal
plate while there is a secondary cold
plate for the vrm as well and that has
thermal pads in all the right places so
that is it for our look at the cards
themselves how well these perform in
terms of kind of noise levels and
temperatures we will start with
temperatures first and things are pretty
much as expected so our found position
we saw the GPU peak at 75 degrees
although MSI was able to reduce this by
seven degrees with the GPU at 68 degrees
so both results like I said pretty much
as expected with our found Edition
running one degree hotter than the
original 2080 super but still two
degrees cooler than the 2080 ti the
founder's does run a little bit louder
than the original 2080 however with
noise levels peaking around 44 decibels
which is audible but still not very
annoying whatsoever although as expected
M aside does significantly reduce that
down to just under 39 decibels that is
still about 2 decibels louder than the
2070 super gaming extreme although again
I suppose that is to be expected
considering it's essentially the same
cooler on a higher core count chip so we
would expect you know slightly higher
temperatures and slightly higher noise
levels to compensate for that core count
increase
is still a fantastically quite card
however and once it is installed in a
case I think you would be really
hard-pressed to actually be able to hear
the fan spinning lastly as for power
consumption while both cars are actually
rated at 250 Watts we did actually see
the gaming extra pull around 12 Watts
more at the wall I think that'd be a
combination of fact there has a slightly
higher clock speed while it also has an
extra fan as well even so both results
are still actually really close to the
20 atti
despite that car being 16% faster on
average so then should you buy the RT X
28 G super in my eyes the answer is a
resounding no for one simple reason it
just represents very poor value for
money should be clear it is actually
still a good card it is faster than the
original twenty eighty and it gives you
very good frameworks at 1440p where it
would be well suited to being paired
with a high refresh rate monitor the
problem is if we compare it to the RT x
2070 super it is just 11 percent faster
and that's for an almost 200 pound
increase that works out as 11 percent
extra performance for a 41% price
increase compared to the RX 5700 XT it
looks even worse with the 2080 Super
approving 16% faster on average though
it costs almost double that AMD card so
just in terms of pure value for money it
is very very unappealing and just looks
very bad value those numbers are
actually all related to the 669 pound
MSRP as well for the rounds Edition but
that doesn't take into account the MSI
gaming Xtreme we don't yet have
confirmed pricing like I said but given
what we've already seen from previous
models of the gaming extreme is likely
to be very expensive with a significant
price premium over the MSRP we've
actually been told about some cards are
going to be priced up to $7.99 and while
I can't yet tell you exactly what the
pricing for this card is gonna be I
would definitely say it will be closer
to 800 pounds than it would be to 700
pounds so that makes the value
proposition look even worse for me that
really does just sum up I think you'd
have to have more money than sense to go
out and buy a 2080 Super when it costs
almost 200 pounds more than the 2070
super yet
the performance increase is relatively
limited like I said to be clear this is
not a bad card it just makes no sense at
its current price of 669 pounds if we're
priced you know 100 pounds cheaper then
it's definitely looking like it making a
little bit more sense as the next step
up but 669 pounds it just represents
very poor value for money so that is it
guys from my review of invidious new
r-tx 2080 super we've also been looking
at the msi r-tx 2080 super gaming Xtreme
if you like this video you can give us a
thumbs up also leave me a comment below
let me know what you think with anyone
go and buy this card for 669 pounds or
even more the msi model do let me know
your thoughts down below please do also
hit that subscribe button and click the
bell so you can be notified about all of
our upcoming videos if you like this
t-shirt I've been wearing today you can
also check out our full range of kick
guru merch which is linked in the
description below and lastly if you
would like to get some of our videos
early as well as access to exclusive
giveaways you can consider backing us on
patreon until then though guys I'm
Dominic Volk go and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]